i got a question about afghanistan did
you uh when when when the u.s went in
did they set up a bunch of checkpoints
requiring an identification from the
citizenry
not and eventually eventually yeah they
had to i mean a checkpoint is a
checkpoint is also a method of area
denial it's not as simple as saying well
we're here for papers please
it's a it's a it is a way to
a checkpoint is it is an uncomfortable
way of saying it's going to get people's
attention and so we can observe people
we basically it's a it's a third it's a
third honey pot
it's a third order right so if i put a
checkpoint out here i can also watch how
people move around that checkpoint or
maybe if that checkpoint is so that they
can't come into the embassy
that's pretty straightforward but i'm
going for a segway here so did you ever
force people if they want was there ever
a policy where was like people could not
freely use services anywhere during
these operations unless they had id to
prove who they were or what you know
what they were doing i think i see where
this is going oh you see where this is
going yeah yeah making a point about a
military occupation versus what we're
seeing in our country right now yeah
that was too special checkpoints you
were what i said i was too special for
that segue checkpoints an inflated ego
conversation i think i think what we
could say though is that
there was a lot certainly a lot of
vetting that went on for people that
were in these uh these joint units
people who were allowed to join the ana
also people who served as contractors um
of host nation uh nationals that were
serving on bases there was a ton of
vetting that went into this there were
biometrics that were were conducted and
that even with all of this vetting that
was done you still had a massive amount
of what we're called green on blue
attacks and you cannot talk about
resettling afghanistan refugees in quote
unquote refugees in the united states
without confronting that very real fact
that even the people who were vetted and
many times this is we're talking about
stream vetting right yeah we're still
connected these groundable attacks yeah
what's a green on blue so green on blue
attack means
you know so blue forces is like me and
my allies that's my buddies red forces
that's the bad guy that's uh that's
that's the enemy right but green is the
sort of you know you're a host nation
uh
national you're a host country national
or you know you're so you're someone
who's working for us in a in a
contractor capacity or civilian capacity
you're not but you're not you know one
of our one of our allies in in uniform
right um i knew a guy who got you know
the defect he got shot in the ga in the
cafeteria as he was waiting in line to
get chow one day right by by someone who
was working there just got shot in the
stomach
wow just right just
waiting in line for the for the knuckle
draggers out there like me in that sense
uh well okay so for that since green on
blue green is afghan in this scenario
green was the afghan military and then
blue is american right sometimes it was
accidental sometimes it was not
accidental
man so well so so the the point i was
trying to get to was i was trying to be
rather disparaging of of new york
considering we're talking about war and
all that and hearing about you know just
these the things that you were able to
not able to do and then i think about
what's happening in our own country and
it kind of feels like it's beyond
occupation right you know so
my question was general not that you
ever operated a checkpoint or there were
checkpoints right and by the time i was
i was more involved by the time i spent
more time in kabul most of those
checkpoints within the city were
run by afghan nationals which had there
was
there was easily examples of layers of
corruption there bribes beyond reason i
mean it doesn't matter but there were
checkpoints within major cities
and there were also checkpoints
um between certain political standpoints
actually my one jsoc buddy always has
this great line about that it's it's
quick i know you want to segue but you
got to hear this one so it's it because
it talks about the moral differences
right so he would say in the united
states we consider it corrupt if you are
a government official and you give jobs
to your family
in afghanistan you are considered
corrupt if you're a government official
and you don't give jobs to your family
so now what we have here in the u.s in
new york is substantially worse than any
kind of checkpoint or
uh
you know i guess general search in a
designated area we have you can't enter
buildings that would happen without an
id all right so i uh actually uh you
know if you guys saw i was on fox news
earlier and for those listening on the
watching the clip i'll probably they'll
probably put a clip above it um because
i did you know as i've been mentioning
for the past couple of days i did a
bunch of phone calls i called the city
and what's happening in new york is
substantially worse than a military
occupation that you have to fire your
employees if they have a disability
barring them from vaccination you you
want to enter any building you got to
have an id a company must terminate
their employees and so i'm thinking
about this stuff i'm like how did we get
to the point where new york has
basically violated civil rights law
across the board from the federal
government without and how does this
happen how does it happen that in our
own cities
you know you can't even you can't even
shoot at a guy if he's got a machine gun
pointed at you but in new york they can
straight up say the ada is in the toilet
we can do whatever we want
it's a million times well
there's a lot there's a lot worse with
actual military conflict but i tell you
man the nazis they went after the
disabled first and now we're at the
point we're watching this in four cities
you've got la sf new orleans and new
york under these lockdowns
you are getting to a situation in the
united states
where
it's it's really amazing and you could
get into the moral and ideological
implications of why this is but
it is a medical part it is medical
apartheid
you are having people that are being
told because of their personal decisions
or their personal medical history that
they are no longer allowed to
participate in society and
those same people are also if you watch
certain other media a lot of mainstream
media now they are being demonized they
are being authorized they are being
labeled and they are being more and more
when i say demonized i really mean that
because the the president united states
just gave a speech today joe biden gave
a speech today talking about how it's
the unvaccinated's fault that all this
is going on it is your fault you are the
ones that you are the reason that this
pandemic is still going on you need to
do this we need to push this in those
governors that are standing in the way
of masks they're standing in the way of
mandates they need to stop and they need
to get with the program you know you
know what word i like that everyone
seems to be using now anathematize
what's that mean uh it's like a a a
condemnation from the cathedral like an
official curse or condemnation from the
authority
so
that's
what we're seeing the i guess what would
be the uh anathematization there you go
of groups of groups of people be it
because they have personal medical
issues that aren't necessarily
disabilities but they have to make hard
choices or because they have just
personal choice and by all means i i'm
sure the people can you want to make an
argument say well your personal choice
is bad for us i don't choose to drive
drunk i'm like okay that's not the same
argument but i'll tell you this what
about somebody who goes to the doctor
the doctor says no and now
when you go to these restaurants what
happens they say i'm sorry you're fired
because of your disability but it's not
it's not i don't want to make it seem
like nobody's fighting back because we
do have an article from over at
timcast.com restaurants sue mayor bill
de blasio over vaccine passport mandate
a group of restaurants and businesses in
new york city have filed a lawsuit
against mayor bill de blasio over the
vaccine passport and this is interesting
they mention there is no um there's no
medical exemptions there's there's
exemptions for celebrities performers
yeah that's right if you book a show you
don't got to be a celebrity to book a
show you're good don't worry about it we
don't we don't we don't we don't need
that from you the new york post reports
and the lawsuit filed on tuesday in
staten island supreme court the
businesses argued the mandate violates
their constitutional rights and unfairly
targets certain establishments because
churches grocery stores schools offices
and medical facilities do not have the
same strict requirement additionally the
mandate does not make any allowances for
people who cannot get the vaccine or
already have antibodies from having the
virus it makes no exception for people
allergic to the ingredients in the
vaccines have religious beliefs against
them or have pre-existing conditions
so uh one of our friends made a phone
call
and asked a restaurant if they would bar
someone with a disability from coming in
as you guys know i talked about how i
made this phone call and they said
i'm sorry regardless if you don't have
the vaccine you can't come in and he
said uh what about a jewish person would
you would you let them in and they said
what do you mean like if if they were
instructed you know because of their
religious beliefs they couldn't and
they're like oh absolutely not they
wouldn't be allowed in the establishment
the religious beliefs do not
give you any kind of exemption from from
this well and by the way you know
as um
you know as the uh the category token
catholic on the on the podcast and since
no shim cast tonight
tonight
but um and really just for christians as
well though that they that so in in the
catholic faith in the christian faith uh
abortion is obviously something that's
completely against our religion it is i
mean it is uh throughout the bible etc
not to get all that but it is 100
against
a lot of the vaccines used aborted
fetuses in their development and so a
lot of people have looked at that in
good faith and say look this is this is
just against my religious beliefs to use
something that benefited and was created
through abortion that this is something
that is completely against our religious
beliefs it's something that we believe
in our core and it's something that we
completely reject and it goes deeper too
because you're using the term anathema
and that term has a long history i mean
being catholic i would figure
the history of the term anathemas to be
cutting you off from the source of
salvation right so the idea is if you're
anathema i am being able to whether it
whether
so i'm not catholic i'm reformed
um but uh i'm
and in that sense we may have different
beliefs but the the concept remains the
same it is as if somebody were to say
you are no longer or you are not saved
we are cut off from the grace of christ
so that's a heavy thing to say and your
paralyze your your parallel to it though
is very important here because you're
also now dealing in
major cultural differences that we're
starting to see on the metaphysics level
we believe in a difference between
positive and negative rights
so a negative right is such that i
cannot impose on something to you i
cannot it is a it is be fouling your
rights it is it is i have a great way to
explain positive and negative rights
good a negative right to life means i
can't kill someone a positive right to
life means i'm obligated to try and save
you if i see you dying yes and we don't
believe in the same positive rights as
in i don't have to go out of my way to
prevent you
from
something right but what you're seeing
especially in this example
is that
people are viewing
the
conscious decision not to get the
vaccine as in as a violation of somebody
else's negative rights
you're seeing this in the land we've but
this is nothing new this is nothing new
we've been seeing it on the colleges for
years
you know silence is violence it's all
the same thing you know people were
saying for the longest time once these
college kids get out of school the real
world and i said it how many times i
probably said it 500 times over the past
couple of years yeah once these kids get
into the real world i however i want to
be fair to myself and say i've always i
still have always had but maybe what
happens is they graduate college and get
jobs here and the companies just do what
they want i guess right yeah they do
they get jobs in hr and then they
control your company and they tell you
who that you can and cannot hire based
on race and gender and and because or
whatever ebermex candy says today well i
wasn't i wasn't actually going to go
into this but you just gave us a good
way to put in it put it out that when
you said it is your connection from
the source of grace right that is
anathema well that is what they see
themselves as doing right right so these
government leaders political leaders
establishment leaders they view the
power of government and good society as
being on the side of grace as that's why
the term cathedral is used so often
right it's because we are on the side of
the angels this our progressive world
sphere and our control over this part of
society is grace and there is nothing
higher right because they're
materialistic even this is it even
though if you have broken one of our
social commandments then we must cut you
off are you saying but it's it's
materialism as well it's it's straight
up it's not even the metaphysical it's
not even the grace it's literally like
the you want to use our banks it's it's
all i don't know
here's another way of dividing that
question yeah are you saying that it's
it's the are you saying that
um the issue with their belief system is
that they believe it or is it the belief
system itself they view this is
again i'm going to actually tie this
into a similarity between something like
uh russian communism the government is
god
the government is holy they got
everything the government says it's like
a great example would be the first
episode of that hbo miniseries on
chernobyl well the government just said
it couldn't happen so it's not happening
like they believed themselves as the
author and dictator of reality right
that's how so convoluted they got now
you're looking at early stage issues
with that where they is are you saying
that the problem that you have with
their belief system is that they believe
it so holy they believe in the holiness
of the state so well or is it is it the
fact that they believe it itself or is
it the belief is it what they believe or
that they believe it because
i would say something like i believe
that
i insert some easy one i believe that
murder is wrong okay so and i believe
that with absolute conviction that for
me to just go murder out of greed or
whatever is wrong
okay so i believe that with absolute
conviction
am i wrong because i believe it or is my
belief wrong
so is there belief in the
uh the cathedral the the the new
inquisition
non-catholic church but the new
inquisition of the state
as being holy
is that's i think that's where it's
wrong that they view themselves wrong
well no it's not both wrong because i
can't fault them for believing something
but i can say that their belief is wrong
yeah they believe that the government is
telling them the truth they believe in
the power of the science cnn what they
believe is kind of all changes by the
day depending on what the cdc comes out
with this the state is what they want
the ccp believes in their
accomplishments and and right they
believe and believe it was given to them
by heaven or whatever do they though do
they really i don't know i mean i maybe
maybe not but they believe it and so we
can't fault people for believing things
let's put it this way alone it's it's
not just the belief it's the enforcement
that's the issue right the issue is the
enforcement of the belief if there is
somebody out there that you know praises
the national register and you see these
people who actually have little like
shrines to dr fauci in their homes while
they call trump supporters occult um
and they're singing you know broadway
musicals that they've changed the words
out and put in with dr fauci
um that they are quite literally they're
quite literally
um making him as an avatar of government
and idol right they're idolizing
government and so they are making
government in this case the state and
writ large the overstate would you if
you combine academia and some elements
of the corporate sphere in this that
they are then enforcing that through
what you just said in new york they're
cultural institutions now the cultural
institutions are enforcing that belief
on everybody and that's the issue thanks
for checking out this clip from the tim
cast irl podcast if you want to see the
full show come back to this channel
youtube.com tim cast irl monday through
friday at 8pm where you can leave
comments and super chat and we actually
will read your comments on the show
don't forget to like share subscribe and
if you want exclusive members only
content segments you can't get anywhere
else go to timcast.com become a member
and we even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you